Puede que esta música esté sonando, en este mismo momento, en algún lugar más allá
del Sistema Solar. La Quinta Sinfonía de
Beethoven está grabada en el disco de oro
que viaja dentro de la sonda Voyager. El objetivo
de la Voyager no es otro que darnos a conocer
ante cualquier forma de vida extraterrestre
que la encuentre.
Mientras tanto el 2 de marzo de 2019, Space
X realizó el primer vuelo de prueba de lo
que en un futuro serán viajes comerciales
al espacio.
“KENNEDY: We choose to go to the moon…”
En las últimas décadas, los seres humanos
hemos soñado con romper la última frontera.
Descubrir nuevos planetas, conocer otras formas
de vida… pero la exploración espacial tiene
otros atractivos que no se suelen mencionar.
Exacto, hablamos de dinero. Nuestro sistema
solar está lleno de recursos naturales. Todos
esos asteroides que viajan por el universo
están llenos de oro, platino y toda clase
de metales. Incluso algunas lunas de Saturno
son auténticas bolas gigantes de gas natural
¿Pensabas que algún día se agotarían los
recursos naturales de la Tierra? Pues tranquilo
porque ahí fuera hay miles de yacimientos
por explotar. Y sí, todo eso supone una auténtica
fortuna. La minería espacial es la industria
del futuro… ¿O tal vez del presente? ¿Y
qué tiene que ver Luxemburgo con todo esto?
Pues atentos porque el vídeo de hoy os va
a dejar boquiabiertos.
Hay una pregunta que todos nos hemos hecho
alguna vez: ¿Existe vida inteligente en otros
planetas? Pero yo tengo una pregunta aún
más interesante ¿A quién le importa la
vida inteligente en Marte cuando podemos encontrar
recursos naturales y hacer dinero? ¿Os imagináis
que pudiéramos sacar uranio de una mina en
un asteroide? ¿Qué pudiéramos extraer gas
natural en Saturno? No. No me he vuelto loco.
Lo cierto es que la minería espacial es ya
una realidad.
Una nave especial japonesa, Hayabusa 2, llega
al asteroide Ryugu para extraer minerales
¡Y no creáis que hablamos de poco dinero!
Para que os hagáis una idea, cerca de la
tierra hay un asteroide que se llama Davida.
Tiene un diámetro de poco más de 3 campos
de futbol. Pero recursos naturales por valor
de… atentos, 27 QUATRILLONES de dólares.
Es decir, estamos hablando de un 27 seguido
de 18 ceros.
¡Pero no es el único! En Saturno hay un
satélite que se llama TITAN y que está hecho,
literalmente, de gas metano. Es decir, que
es una bola entera de gas liquado que podría
suministrar a todo el planeta tierra durante
siglos. Esto podría ser el fin de las guerras
del gas, de la dependencia que tenemos de
dictaduras que tienen en recursos naturales.
Suena fantástico ¿Verdad? Pero aquí viene
la gran pregunta. Imaginad que queremos explotar
una mina de oro en Australia. En este caso,
tendremos que seguir la legislación australiana
¿verdad? Cada país tiene su propia legislación,
algunos más estricta, otros menos… pero
está claro quién legisla qué. Sin embargo
¿Qué pasa si explotamos un satélite en
la órbita de Saturno? ¿A quién pertenece
eso? ¿Quién regula los derechos de propiedad?
Por ejemplo, imaginad que tenemos una empresa
de minería y nos vamos al asteroide DAVIDA
para extraer el hierro que contiene. Pero,
a la vez que llegamos nosotros, llega otra
empresa a disputarnos la mina ¿Cómo resolvemos
el problema? ¿Con que ley? ¿En qué tribunal?
Pues bien, hasta ahora, nadie se había preocupado
por legislar la minería espacial… bueno,
hay un país que sí ha empezado a hacer sus
deberes ¡Exacto! Hablamos de LUXEMBURGO.
Luxemburgo es ese país situado entre Bélgica,
Francia y Alemania que tiene menos población
que todo Manhattan.
¿Y qué tienen de especial en Luxemburgo?
Una palabra: DINERO. Si recordáis, en este
vídeo os contábamos que Luxemburgo es uno
de los países más ricos del mundo. Pues
bien, cuando tienes dinero, lo inviertes.
Hablamos con poco más de medio millón de
habitantes, pero ya ha invertido más de 220
millones de dólares en minería espacial.
Tienen el capital, tienen las empresas ¿Qué
les faltaba? ¡La legislación! ¡Pues…
aquí la tenéis!
“Nuestro objetivo es crear un entorno legislativo
para la exploración y uso comercial de los
recursos de los llamados “cuerpos celestiales”
como asteroides o incluso la Luna.
Etienne Schneider, ex Primer Ministro de Luxemburgo
y actual ministro de economía.
Según varias empresas del sector, para el
año 2025 ya será rentable extraer cosas
como agua, hidrógeno y metales preciosos.
Pero la pregunta es ¿Cómo funciona la minería
espacial? ¿Y cómo va a funcionar esta legislación?
¿Estamos hablando de algo serio o sólo son
rumores? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
EL ORO MARCIANO
Como os podéis imaginar, mandar una nave
especial a un asteroide es caro. Muy caro.
Así que, si Mahoma no puede ir a la montaña…
la montaña va a Mahoma. Literalmente.
Hablamos de mover asteoides fuera de su camino
habitual y ponerles en la órbita de nuestro
planeta. Y diréis ¿Es esto posible? Pues
la respuesta es sí. Según un estudio del
Instituto KECK, “capturar” asteroides
va a ser una realidad muy pronto. Y pensad
que este estudio se publicó en el año 2012.
7 años antes de que hagamos este vídeo.
En ese tiempo, las investigaciones han avanzado
una barbaridad.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ¡Fonseca!
¿Pero qué te has fumado? Pues no tenemos
nada mejor que hacer que construir una grúa
de proporciones nachovidalianas para enganchar
asteroides.
¡A ver! ¡Tranquilos! El proceso es bastante
más sencillo. Veréis, basta con que un asteroide
se acerque lo suficiente a un cuerpo más
grande, como pueda ser la Luna o nuestro propio
planeta como para que la masa de la Tierra
lo arrastre a su órbita. Así que, lo único
que tenemos que hacer es “empujar” un
poco el asteroide para que se desvíe de su
rumbo y se acerque a nuestra órbita. Todo
esto podría hacerse con una especie de misil
teledirigido.
Sin embargo, todo esto es la teoría. Y ahora
os preguntaréis ¿Pero… hay alguien que
ya se haya puesto a picar piedra en un asteroide?
Y la respuesta es sí.
La Agencia Espacial Japonesa, mandó una nave,
la HAYABUSA a un asteroide que se llama 25143
ITOKAWA. Así que la primera muestra de minerales
espaciales llegó a la tierra en el año 2010.
Poco después, en 2016, la Nasa mandó otra
nave, la llamada OSIRIS REX al asteroide BENNU.
En este caso, las muestras llegarán en el
año 2023. Y, en este caso, ya se pondrán
en práctica muchas de las tecnologías de
minería espacial.
Sin embargo, no todo es tan sencillo. Muchos
de estos satélites giran en torno a sí mismos
a una velocidad tan rápida que es, prácticamente,
imposible poderlos manejar. Eso significa,
que en muchos casos habría que rodear estos
cuerpos con cables que limitaran su movimiento.
Y como os podéis imaginar, eso es extremadamente
caro.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque todo esto
son los problemas técnicos! Pero esto es
VisualPolitik. Aquí hablamos de política
y de economía. Y creedme, la minería espacial
plantea un montón de problemas en este sentido.
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LUXEMBURGO: IMPERIO GALÁCTICO
En el año 1967 se aprobó el primer tratado
internacional sobre el Espacio Exterior. Eran
los años de la Guerra fría y a nadie le
importaba eso de la minería espacial. El
auténtico terror de la época que Estados
Unidos o la Unión Soviética usaran los satélites
para aniquilarse el uno al otro. Y eso es
en lo que se centra este tratado.
Pero los tratados internacionales son una
cosa bastante rara. No hay ninguna policía
mundial que pueda obligar a los estados a
cumplirlos. Todo lo que se puede hacer es
imponer sanciones comerciales. Así que, en
la práctica, la legislación internacional
es como las reglas del parchís: cada uno
las interpreta como quiere.
Como nota curiosa, os diré que Donald Trump
ya está barajando la idea de crear un ejército
espacial.
“El otro día estaba pensando “oye, hacemos
un trabajo tremendo en el espacio, a lo mejor
tendríamos que crear un ejército espacial.
No lo decía en serio pero luego me dije “eh!
Pues es una buena idea! Igual lo tenemos que
hacer!”
Por extraño que suene, esta no es la primera
vez que un presidente estadounidense dice
algo así. En el año 1983, Ronald Regan propuso
construir el llamado “Proyecto de la Guerra
de las Galaxias”. La idea era poner una
red de satélites capaces de interceptar un
posible ataque de misiles soviéticos. El
proyecto era tan caro que tuvieron que cerrarlo.
Pero, desde luego, a nadie parecía importarle
que ese proyecto violara flagrantemente el
Tratado del Espacio Exterior.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué dice la legislación
internacional sobre el la minería espacial?
Pues, básicamente, dos cosas. La primera
es que cualquier organización no gubernamental,
lo cual incluye a las empresas, necesita el
permiso de un estado para poder marcharse
al espacio exterior. La segunda, es que nadie
puede restringir la investigación científica
pero… ¿Qué pasa con la explotación comercial?
¡Ah! Pues no se sabe.
Y por eso, tanto Estados Unidos como Luxemburgo
han sacado sus propias leyes para permitir
que los inversores se puedan lanzar a la carrera
espacial.
Y esto es muy importante porque tanto Luxemburgo
como Estados Unidos tienen una cosa muy especial.
Veréis, en casi todos los países del mundo,
los recursos naturales se consideran estratégicos.
Es decir, que si tu vives en Argentina, por
ejemplo, y te encuentras petróleo en tu jardín…
¡No puedes explotarlo porque no es tuyo!
Ese petróleo es del Gobierno y, por tanto,
ellos deciden cuando, cómo y quien explota
ese zumo de dinosaurio.
Sin embargo, si vives en California, o en
Luxemburgo, y encuentras petróleo en tu jardín
¡Estás de enhorabuena! Ese petróleo es
tuyo y lo explotas cuando, cómo y con quien
quieras.
Pero el caso de Luxemburgo es aún más especial
que el del Tío Sam. Tienen una ventaja única.
Veréis, la ley estadounidense dice que sólo
las empresas nacionales pueden tener permiso
para explotar minas en el espacio ¿Y qué
hace falta para que una empresa sea estadounidense?
Pues… tiene que tener sus oficinas dentro
del país y los dueños tienen que ser residentes
estadounidenses.
Sin embargo, en el caso de Luxemburgo, basta
con tener una oficina fiscal en Luxemburgo.
Es decir, que te basta con hacer un trámite
burocrático y tener un buzón en el país
para que te lleguen las cartas de Hacienda.
Nada más. En otras palabras, imaginad que
una empresa Australiana quisiera explotar
recursos en un satélite. Basta con que hagan
un viaje de ida y vuelta al país de Jean
Claude Juncker y ¡Boom! Ya pueden irse a
donde quieran.
Por si todo esto fuera poco… Luxemburgo
tiene muchos menos impuestos que Estados Unidos.
En otras palabras: con la ley estadounidense,
sólo los estadounidenses se pueden beneficiar
de la minería espacial. Sin embargo, Luxemburgo
acaba de abrir todo un nuevo sector económico
al mundo entero. Y eso explica que tantísimos
inversores hayan elegido este país para sus
proyectos.
Hablamos de un sector tan grande, que ya existe
todo un cluster empresarial dedicado a la
minería del espacio. Es decir, una asociación
empresarial apoyada por el propio gobierno
para dar visibilidad a todos estos proyectos.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hablamos de
30 empresas, con 700 trabajadores y que ya
genera un volumen de negocio de 2000 millones
de euros.
Como os podéis imaginar, hay muchísimas
voces críticas. Las Naciones Unidas, entre
otros. Algunos economistas de izquierdas como
Gabriel Zucman, que es un discípulo de Thomas
Piketti, han llegado a decir cosas como esta.
Luxemburgo está extendiendo la lógica de
ser un paraíso fiscal a una nueva área
Y lo cierto es que todavía hay un par de
problemas legales que Luxemburgo necesitará
resolver ¿Recordáis ese tratado espacial
de 1967? Pues bien, en el artículo 1 dice
que los estados estarán obligados a compartir
los beneficios de sus exploraciones con el
resto del mundo. Pero ¿Qué significa esto?
Pues… nadie lo sabe a ciencia cierta. ¿Significa
que si sacamos oro de un asteroide, lo tenemos
que repartir a partes iguales entre los más
de 190 países del mundo? ¿Cómo? ¿Quién
hace el reparto? ¿Se lo damos a cada gobierno?
¿O tal vez nos limitamos a pagar un impuesto?
En ese caso… ¿Quién lo cobra? ¿El gobierno
del… mundo? También podríamos decir que,
traer recursos naturales al planeta tierra
es algo necesario de lo que nos beneficiamos
todos indirectamente. En otras palabras, que
se trata de un párrafo abierto a todo tipo
de interpretaciones.
Pero todo esto no son más que futuribles.
Así que ahora, la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que Luxemburgo podrá terminar creando
su propio imperio espacial? ¿Hasta qué punto
este país tan pequeño puede cambiar la economía
mundial? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios. Y, como siempre, no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribios a VisualPolitik para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado el vídeo, dadle a LIKE y
nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.